christena now has kovat she is now
positive Chris Cuomo revealed on
Wednesday that his wife Christina has
contracted the corona virus it just
breaks my heart the CNN anchor shared
the news during his show Cuomo prime
time while talking to his brother New
York Governor Andrew Cuomo it's very
rare for a family to be one and done
Christina now has kovat she is now
positive and it just breaks my heart it
is the one thing I was hoping wouldn't
happen and now it has now a source close
to the Cuomo family tells ET Chris is
beating himself up over her diagnosis
adding that while Christina symptoms
aren't as bad as Chris's right now they
are worried because they know things can
get bad with this virus quickly
well the beast comes at night you know
as we know the health care workers like
have taken to calling the virus the
beast I understand why my fever has gone
up a couple of degrees and like the last
30 minutes nights are tough
Chris tested positive for köppen 19 over
two weeks ago
I tested positive scare yes as you might
imagine but better me than you and has
been self quarantine in the family's
basement my wife and my kids thank God
didn't have it look how lucky I got here
even though Chris did his best to
isolate himself from his family andrew
explained that the odds weren't in their
favor when all is said and done I don't
think this is a bad experience for them
to go through you want to talk about
growing up a little bit and seeing
reality a little bit Bella will step up
so it's it's all going to be fine I I
know it makes a bad situation worse but
it's all going to be fine at the end
Chris and Christina who had been married
for nearly two decades share three kids
seventeen-year-old daughter Bella 14
year old son Mario and an 11 year old
daughter Karolina and Chris said he's
holding out hope that Christina symptoms
won't be as bad as his the 49 year old
has been pretty candid about his
symptoms which included weight loss
I've lost 13 pounds in three days
meeting and drinking constantly I'm just
sweating it out and it's the sickness
high fever 102 103 103 plus that
wouldn't quit and it was like somebody
was beating me like a pinata
and hallucinations due to that fever I
was up all night was wrong I'm telling
you I was hallucinating
it was freaky what I lived through last
night and it may happen again tonight ET
sources the Cuomo's are worried about
their kids
but everyone is pitching in to help keep
the house running especially Bella who
the source says is an amazing young lady
they're helping each other they're more
quiet they're focused on her and
hopefully it makes the family even
stronger